[Musik]
name entscheiden und diplom ingenieur
habe allerdings den beruf des
anlagenmechanikers damals dieser noch
gas und wasserinstallateur auch selber
gelernt und ausgeübt und bin jetzt seit
16 2002 hier in der firma als
geschäftsführer tätig und auch als
gesellschafter mein name ist patrick
hemmer und ich bin anlagenmechaniker
gelernt und habe die ausbildung vor
zirka anderthalb jahren abgeschlossen
in andreas mundt ich komme hier aus
alfter mache jetzt zwei jahren die
ausbildung zum anlagenmechaniker im
bereich heizung sanitär und klimatechnik
ist sehr vielfältig und
abwechslungsreich man kann mit kunden zu
tun hat mit kollegen zu tun und hat im
team zu tun wenn man jetzt auf der
baustelle man ist auch in der werkstatt
die hauptthemen sind natürlich war
sanierung gästen sanierung und im
bereich kundendienst wo kleine
reparaturen gemacht werden und wartungen
an kesseln durchgeführt werden als
anlagenmechaniker ist man viel unterwegs
typische tätigkeiten sind zb
wartungsarbeiten anlagemechaniker
kontrollieren ob die heizung richtig
funktioniert sie machen auch reparaturen
zum beispiel in badezimmern sie bauen
komplett neue bäder ein und installieren
fußbodenheizungen mehr über den beruf
des anlagenmechanikers erfahrt ihr im
nächsten teil
sprechen wir mal den heutigen tag
durchstarten könnten wir fangen jetzt
heute morgen an bei der familie jäger
mit einer wartung ok eine heizungsanlage
ja einschließlich mal wasserspeicher
kein problem
wir prüfen das reiten so wird die dass
wir das immer üblich genau da habe ich
termine vereinbart zwischen 8 und 9 uhr
ja ja als nächstes zwischen 10 11 uhr
haben wir fünf ventil bei der familie
schirrmann ok vielfalt ihrer
spielklassen zu tauschen
wir haben ja und der rest vom tag ist
dann wahrscheinlich schon sehr
anstrengend programm könnte eine stunde
länger werden bei der baustelle
himberger 8 und 22 in dem badezimmer bei
der badsanierung die fusion muss noch
fertig verlegt werden
ok und die muss heute aber komplett
rheinland warum stand der smi hat der
erste schläger was mit der unternehmen
zu tun oder machen wir dass das machen
wir alles komplett alles klar
ja wir brauchen einmal unser für ventil
ja habe ich dann brauchen wir unseren
umsatz für die wartung und als nächstes
brauchen wir noch unsere verschraubung
für die fußbodenheizung brauchen jetzt
bitte einmal die waschmaschine mit ja
als die schule und die überfischung und
jetzt haben wir noch den mess koffer den
taktisch noch mit 1
hatte
[Musik]
ja einmal bitte warten natürlich werden
jetzt etwas auslegen und auch um die
heizung kümmern danke dann werden wir
uns morgen die heizung kommen was muss
man als erstes machen aufmachen
ausschalten besonders aus werden wir
unten war das mal angucken wieder den
raum aussieht
du holst jetzt bitte mal den staubsauger
ja und dann werden wir mal den brennraum
aus
[Musik]
so werden wir den asche behälter aus
lernt
[Musik]
und wer das gehst du bitte mal den
messkopf vom auto in der klassik gibt es
nur wird das messgerät
[Applaus]
was gibt es denn für eine obergrenze für
den ceo wird beim terror wird ist es so
dass wir möglichst tief sein sollte in
der regel der so bei 15 ok aber wenn er
dann höre schießen sollte auf bis über
500 dann wird die anlage so vorstelle
überlegt weil das schädlich oder in zu
hoher konzentration in die luft kommt
okay aber das hier das passt wir haben
ihre heizung beraten nach der heizung
muss alles in ordnung
ich habe hier unseren zettel
fertiggemacht wir haben die anlage
gewartet
wir haben auch die abgase gemessen das
passt alles gut dann müssen sie sich
keine sorgen machen
wir waren und da bekomme ich bitte von
ihnen dort eine unterschiedliche super
danke ich wünsche ihnen auch nicht
unbedingt auge verabschieden
[Applaus]
so und erst wenn jetzt das ventil
wechseln müssen
okay der spülkasten durchläuft das heißt
das für ein tier schließt nicht mehr und
durch den überlauf das ganze wasser in
die toilette reinke dazu werden wir die
platte machen verschwunden lösen
die haltung heraus dass der einspruch
das ganze hat ihre position wieder
montieren
jetzt muss man das ganze rückwärts
wieder zusammen wurden das wars
guten tag
die firma sheldon mein name das hemme
das ist der kollegen lahm und wir sind
hier für die badsanierung belegen heute
fußboden heute in den badezimmern haben
folgende situation jahren davor nicht
den waschtisch hier kommt das mitzählen
wir sind heute hier um die
fußbodenheizung zulegen können alles
klar
[Applaus]
eine fußbodenheizung verlegt waren sie
angeschlossen und sie ist dicht und
damit sind wir fertig für heute ich habe
jetzt in den zettel fertig gemacht herr
das bin ich dass es der kollege ja heute
und wir waren jetzt insgesamt drei
stunden hier gewesen h
wir haben die fußbodenheizung verlegt
angeschlossen und auf dichtigkeit
überprüft und dann bekomme ich bitte
hier unten eine unterschrift von dass
jetzt insgesamt lang sechs stunden oder
zwei stunden und insgesamt sechs stunden
vielen dank
sind sehr sehr ab werk
und der song der anspruch von
trinkwasser zu tun das lebensmittel
nummer eins man hat mit energien zu tun
mit gas und öl mit pellets mit wärme
modernsten techniken man sollte auf
jeden fall spaß am handwerk haben und
auch spaß an groben arbeiten aber auch
spaß an filigranen arbeiten weil dieses
kommt alles zusammen und das von minute
eins an ein guter anlagenmechaniker muss
logisch denken muss in mathematik ganz
gut sein und muss im prinzip auch spaß
am handwerk haben und auch mit seinen
händen arbeiten können die ausbildung
dauert dreieinhalb jahre und ist
aufgeteilt in schulisch und praktische
arbeiten man hat immer zwei oder einen
tag in der woche schule und den rest ist
man mit den kollegen unterwegs auf den
baustellen erstmal als anlagenmechaniker
geselle wenn man weit die ausbildung
selber kann man auf jeden fall im
kundendienst arbeiten man kann auf
baustellen arbeiten man kann neubau
arbeiten
man kann sich natürlich auch
weiterentwickeln man kann nach seinem
bachelor machen dann kann seinen master
machen man kann seinen meister machen
kann seien techniker machen
es gibt vielfältige
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten unser los und
mehr gefallen am meisten die
badsanierung weil man da von minute eins
bei den groben arbeiten schon ganz genau
arbeiten muss sonst wird das endergebnis
nicht dementsprechend wie es gewünscht
ist und dass es halt dieses
faszinierende dass man trotz ziemlich
grobe arbeit und staub und lärm und
dreck schon extrem genau arbeiten ist
das fordert eine hohe konzentration